greetings my friends and welcome to a
bunny Christmas review I have a hunger
for The Grinch who stole Christmas the
Grinch is a hairy piece of snot who
constantly looks down at the whos for
celebrating their holiday Christmas they
of course go into great detail about
what Christmas means for the hoos of
course being the birth of who's this the
son of who God and how he ascended into
heaven to absolve all our sins there are
of course different ways to celebrate
this holiday including Hanukkah who
don't believe that whose this was the
who SIA but either way the Grinch does
not believe it who's this Christ because
he has a who dissed and he wants to
persecute those who go against his who
disbelieves by stealing Christmas so he
dresses up like Saint Nick because
apparently the who's also had a Saint
Nick and sneak Son down into the village
to steal Christmas but in the process of
stealing Christmas he comes across a
little who Cindy Lou Who who is no more
than two in this version the Grinch pets
her on the head and gets her a drink and
sends her up to bed which I thought was
very strange why don't you get someone
to drink before they go to bed then I
realized soos needed something to rhyme
with stuff the tree up and woke up with
only word you could think of it you know
why I'm thinking too hard about it
The Grinch gets all of Christmas and his
wily coyote bags but notices that the
hoos are celebrating Christmas anyway
they all hold hands and sing around a
giant glowing light in the middle of the
city
obviously Christmas was something a
whole lot more than the creature
expected there was a ball of radioactive
energy that they all seemed to gather
around and celebrate at the same time
I'm not gonna question why they
celebrate this glowing orb in the middle
of the
it's their holiday they can do whatever
they want I've heard a much stranger of
religious beliefs even some that judge
and persecute others because they can't
agree on the best way to love one
another
but enough about every Facebook quote
you've ever seen The Grinch comes down
to the village returns all their
presents and they celebrate their love
and appreciation for all living things
by killing and eating a dead animal
incidentally I think that was the
cabinet has cameo this is chittery
Buddha saying don't go away Christmas I
want to stay in this robe